[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
happy tuesday
or should i say
happy trader day what the [ __ ] is
confederate memorial day
what are you memorializing
you're a [ __ ] loser is it surprising
that the trump shark army is all on
board with traitor with traitor day
happy traitor day
it is not surprising that the trump
shark army loves to celebrate
confederate memorial day
apparently that's the state of south
carolina it's a state holiday
states rights are states wrongs as it
should be jesus [ __ ] christ when why
can't we [ __ ] realize
that a bunch of [ __ ] traitors are not
people we want to memorialize in this
country
regardless if it was during the the
confederacy of the united states
or the cheeto dust confederacy which we
have now
apparently
the cheeto dust confederacy is
absolutely frightened their kryptonite
is sidewalk chalk
you heard this story susan collins calls
the police
i'm calling the police you [ __ ] you
chalked up my sidewalk it rained and it
was washed away less than two hours you
sons of [ __ ]
it really is [ __ ] hilarious
absolutely [ __ ] hilarious
that the insurrectionist
the seditionists the people who wanted
to overturn our constitution who want to
take away your [ __ ] liberty and your
[ __ ] rights away from you
and they're not it's it's obvious
they're not going to stop it
just women's uteruses
birth control contraception
they're going to tell you what the [ __ ]
to do when you can do it who you could
do it with
that's their goal [ __ ] fascist
it is not surprising that that is the
party that is commemorating
the confederate army jesus [ __ ]
christ memorial day get the [ __ ] out of
here with that [ __ ]
happy nazi day
oh we're gonna celebrate we're gonna
celebrate nazi germany they were our
enemy our mortal enemy they wanted to
destroy
western democracy and
oh my god
you can't you can't [ __ ] make this
[ __ ] up folks
there are states in this country that
are closed today
because the confederate armies our army
were a bunch of [ __ ] traitors and
they lost they [ __ ] lost
it's our heritage
your heritage you're proud of your
heritage
that you fought a war for your ancestors
to own other human beings are you
listening are you even paying the [ __ ]
attention it is 2022 you dumb
[ __ ]
and we think them thinking jfk junior is
going to be the vice president united
states or is the vice president whatever
the [ __ ] these boneheads believe is the
craziest [ __ ] thing they think ah
come on
it's i'm proud i'm proud of my
confederate heritage where we fought for
for my ancestors to own other human
beings
human rights violations
speaking of human rights let's take away
all the rights away from women while
we're at it happy confederate memorial
day
traitors are us
jesus christ you can't make this [ __ ] up
and ted cruz and tucker carlson are
absolutely terrified
terrified a people holding planned
parenthood signs and pink shirts
oh my god it's a mob
it's a mob of people standing still
chanting loudly
oh
alito must be taken out of town that was
all [ __ ] by the way
i guess it's [ __ ] lies uh not
surprising
i i just am very disappointed that the
united states senate decided that they
would protect the supreme court justices
because they've decided that there's
certain people in this country that do
not deserve liberty
that they will protect them from loud
people standing on a public sidewalk but
they won't protect women's rights you
bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's the [ __ ] news
everyone wants to [ __ ] about inflation
the price of bread the price of gas
they're going to take your rights away
you're not even going to be able to go
to a grocery store eventually and buy
this [ __ ]
what the f what the [ __ ] are you worried
about the price of bread for
they're not even gonna allow you to go
into a grocery store eventually
doubt me
you just [ __ ] doubt me i don't tell
you you can you cannot believe me or
believe me i don't give a [ __ ]
give [ __ ] what you do i said they were
gonna ban condoms no tony you're being
ridiculous those are condoms those are
fresh tds
they're trying to ban [ __ ] condoms
tony you said that they're going to try
to ban abortion in in blue states it's
about states rights
they want to have a national ban on
abortion
what don't you [ __ ] understand about
what fascism is what don't you
get
what don't you get
how it works
what their motives are this is really
[ __ ] simple as [ __ ]
they want the power for themselves and
no one else
they want the world for themselves and
no one else
when they say they want their freedom
they mean their freedom no one else's
freedom that's what they mean
that's what the [ __ ] they're talking
about
no better day to celebrate traitors than
confederate memorial day jesus [ __ ]
christ
what in the actual [ __ ]
good morning to you all
even though it's traitor day
good morning to you all happy tuesday
christina amanda is here mj good morning
mj debbie from salt lake is here
brenda's here kimberly is here minus
robin kathy brenda anita from facebook
we've got uh nancy
uh let's see midas margie lisa is
here marty is here from facebook
patricia cheryl from facebook another
cheryl from facebook oh my gosh we have
just we have just got so many people new
watchers welcome welcome new listeners
um if you're not aware
let me tell you how this works we do a
show every single weekday monday through
friday two hours
every day
and we broadcast live on youtube twitter
and twitch
on our channels the tony michaels
podcast so go to go to youtube and
subscribe to the youtube channel just
type in the tony michaels podcast you
will find our channel subscribe there
you're not going to want to miss a thing
we also simulcast
to the minus touch facebook page
all you people out there on face
facebook the books of face welcome
welcome welcome
mayo is here ferret is here ginger from
facebook is here
we just have so many new listeners thank
you very much for for tuning in
to my absolute outrage
oh today we got a lot of video to get to
i'm not sure when the co-host is going
to be here he should be here sometime
close to the bottom of the hour you know
gabe sanchez my executive bruce
and co-host
uh liz from facebook is here josh from
facebook
uh jamie from facebook holy moly paula
cindy carmen
julie
the books of face are hot this morning
hot and ready are you fresh
on traitor day
trader tuesday holy
apparently the state of south carolina
is closed today
to celebrate
the traitors of the confederacy
can we can we just stop this [ __ ] can we
just can we just not do
the whole it's our heritage and we love
our heritage where our
my grandpappy thought it was cool to own
other human beings can we just stop that
nonsense
i mean just just
put a pen in it it's enough of that [ __ ]
we don't need this [ __ ]
we do not need this [ __ ]
oh
okay let's see what else do we have on
the docket today
there is some more news tom brady's in
the news
for i don't know
mean tom brady i guess [ __ ] i don't know
janet yellen is a new ufos is in the
news it's trending ufos folks ufos is
trending gmail and spam is trending
because ronnie jackson does not know how
a spam filter works
now we're going to go through that
no widespread voter fraud is trending on
twitter and macron
is also trending on
twitter the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends
hmm
what else do we have what else do we
have looks like someone's graduating
today we have a
everyone everyone
tell congratulations
kalyn son is graduating today
happy graduation
happy graduation
boy oh boy oh boy
do we have a lot to get to today there's
a ton of video i don't know if you guys
noticed this but i retweet a lot of
video that's usually a good sign of what
the show is gonna be about
uh is the video in the clips that i'm
retweeting yesterday we did not get to
and i want to go ahead and play it now
we did not get to the little video that
um i put some music to you guys know
over the weekend there was a nazi rally
excuse me a cheeto dust confederacy i i
mean a trump queuing on rally
oh it's so much so much to
to do um
and i actually took the video if i can
find the son of a [ __ ] here i actually
took the video and put it to some
different music
really make it better right i felt like
it made the video better
when we put it to this music it is the
trump supporters waiting through the mud
at the trump rally you guys know
that
at trump rallies are held in fields
and like like like you know like a cow
pasture right
do you guys know why
do you guys know why they're held in in
cow pastures
i mean there there's a reason why donald
trump
has to go to a [ __ ] cow pasture
to
to have his rallies you guys know why
right put it in the comments there if
you think you know why i mean i'm gonna
explain it here where in the hell is
this video
i know i posted this thing on on twitter
i know i did where did it go
i know it's here somewhere
we also have proof that um
that marjorie taylor green actually has
more than three toes uh we have
confirmed this
where's this video boy it's really
pissing me off
there we go haha found it
okay here is the rendition
of um you see here you see the mud here
let me make this a little bigger they
had to wade through the mud
to get back to their cars you see this
looks like a
pig pen
right
looks like a pig pen now here's the
reason why trump has to go to these
these cow pastures
the sheep pastures as it were the reason
why trump has to go to these sheep
pastors
is because no one will let him have a
[ __ ] event in their city
no one they won't allow him to go into a
city
and have to pay for like the police
department to secure the city to hire
the state highway patrol and all that
[ __ ]
because he doesn't pay his [ __ ] bills
he wants i mean he owes all kinds of
people money still from the 2020
campaign
so he won't pay his bills so he has to
go have these [ __ ] events in these
cow pastures that's why
because the only the only place he can
go
is a [ __ ] pastor somewhere in bum
[ __ ]
bum [ __ ] nowhere
that's why he goes to these places
so let's listen to this video
because i i may have i may have put a
new sound to this video so check it out
[Music]
oh
let's watch it one more time
listen this is
this is ridiculous that we have to even
oh my god
these are [ __ ] nutty ass people and a
lot of people you know there were some
news coverage like oh look how dedicated
the trump fans are they're even willing
to wade through the mud and the muck
and the storm
the storm is coming folks
and the shark army is there to
celebrate traitor day
just being a bunch of traitors
it just really is um
wild that these people are bragging
about um being ass deep in mud
over a [ __ ] doofus like donald trump
you know
sycophanting
for such a doofus
but here you have it here you have it
and again it's getting harder and harder
and harder to even make fun of these
people it really is it's really getting
difficult to even [ __ ] make fun of
these these knuckleheads
i mean at some point don't you start to
[ __ ] feel sorry for him probably not
but it is getting it is getting a little
old and tired
that we have to clown these people when
they clown themselves
i don't know
i don't know maybe maybe just maybe
we'll make it uh make it to the next the
next trump rally um there was also over
the weekend speaking of some video over
the weekend someone had sent out a video
of uh
some nazis down at disney world
everyone's oh tony
being ridiculous
there's no nazis at disney world
they're not nazis
you're not huh
so you're telling me that that this
in front of the disney world sign aren't
rhonda santa supporters look at this
here look at this here that's a disney
world sign do you see the flag here you
see that little it says the the happiest
place on earth
with the nazi flag watch this video
yep that looks like a nap oh there's
another one nazi and a second nazi
ron desantis supporters show up at
disney world to show their support
of his ideology
and ron desantis i don't think has said
a [ __ ] word about this oh he's he was
talking about communism yesterday
oh how communism bad communism is
communism that we do we do not have we
do not have a communist party in this
country we definitely have a nazi party
in this country a fascist party in this
country
who want to take away people's liberties
want to take away people's rights they
want to rip down our constitution they
want to tear it up they want to smear
[ __ ] all over it
just like they smeared [ __ ] on the
capitol walls
listen this is really [ __ ] dumb
but we have to do this today and the
reason why is because tucker carlson
really is terrified absolutely terrified
of people standing still
in front of a justice's house
a justice that wants to strip away
rights of americans
um let's see if we can find the clip
here here it is
gabe had it
uh gabe says tucker is disgusted
by the mob
if i can there we go the mob
that is standing still watch this video
this is him this is him calling them a
violent mob
okay well let's see
there we go you see the people here
standing
oh my god look at this
look at this pro freedom for all look
look at all these
look at all these uh
these violent
mob
standing there holding a
sign with their not so
not so armed
insurrectionist
they're not beating cops with flags
flagpoles and clubs
they're not breaking windows they're not
tearing down the supreme court they're
not breaking in smearing their [ __ ] all
over the walls in the supreme court
brandishing the the confederate flag
inside of a federal building
they're not doing any of that and tucker
carlson is terrified of people who don't
do violent things
i mean the only way to really have
political discourse in this country is
to violently try to overthrow our
constitution
that's what tucker believes that's what
the republicans believe that's what
these fascists believe
but here we have oh here we have
peaceful protesters talking loud on a
sidewalk outside someone's house who's
trying to strip away rights from the
american people
here we go
we hesitate even bringing these pictures
because they're so awful but it's
happening and you should see what it
looks like
they're so awful oh my god look how
awful this is
look at all these snowflakes that i
claim that are snowflakes and weak and
woke and they're standing there they're
standing there being loud these are
protesters this is the mob
ouch this is the mob
the mob inside justice samuelito's home
in virginia they're disgusting look at
that look at that you know what happened
to before this biden went went to an
event and he riled all these people up
and said march to the justice's house
and take it down take back our supreme
court fight like hell and kick some ant
well that wasn't biden that said that i
don't think biden actually said anything
actually i think they said the opposite
to be frank the bible administration and
the senate are completely wrong here
and anyone who says these protesters
should go home are a bunch of [ __ ]
dummies that's right i said it you
should not be saying that these
protesters these peaceful protesters who
are being loud
should should reverse course and leave
the justices alone [ __ ] that [ __ ]
you definitely definitely definitely
should be loud and protest the [ __ ] out
of this decision
before after
when we finally codify you should be
protesting protesting protesting
in any legal way that you absolutely can
[ __ ] them [ __ ] them
it's absolutely ridiculous that we have
to stand we have to listen to snowflake
tucker carlson crying because a bunch of
people are standing there
you know the scary people in the face
mask
this really is [ __ ] stupid but let's
let's finish
we'll continue to monitor that
throughout the hour we'll continue to
monitor
them standing there protesting
for human rights throughout the hour
what an egregious thing for these people
to stand there and protest the taking
away of human rights
folks you can't make this [ __ ] up you
really can't i wish i wish we could but
we can't
we can't make this [ __ ] up
um let's see uh there's some more video
[Music]
i thought oh yes there was the ted cruz
that's the one i want
ted cruz was on fake news on on uh sean
hannity's show on fake news here
and um he is really upset really upset
that we aren't comparing
these peaceful protesters who are being
loud
to the violent
insurrection the attempted cheeto dust
kangaroo coup it's tried to overturn our
constitution the very document that
these people
are making sure that the justices know
protect their rights we want to
overthrow that constitution that way
they have no rights
[ __ ] ted cruz
it's all politics for them the ends
justify the means and it's complete
hypocrisy you see this in in the
corporate know about hypocrisy democrats
on january 6 of 2021 you had tens of
thousands of people peacefully
protesting and peacefully protesting you
know beating cops killing them giving
them heart attacks pushing their way
into the capital breaking windows
getting shot because they were going
beyond the the borders of safety
for for congress for congressional
members
and senators
they were gonna hang mike pence they
were chanting hang mike pence they
erected a gallows there ted cruz
peacefully protesting these people are
[ __ ] delusional they are [ __ ]
gaslighting [ __ ]
and we have to stop them at every
[ __ ] pass here you have to work your
ass off to to beat back these people
with the ballot
one way to show ted cruz how to [ __ ] all
the way off is texas get engaged
and vote down the ballot starting with
bet o'rourke
that's how you [ __ ] show ted cruz
that you mean [ __ ] business in texas
it's enough of this [ __ ] it's absolutely
enough of this [ __ ] [ __ ] that we
have to put up with a knucklehead like
ted cruz gaslighting the entire country
that somehow january 6 was [ __ ]
peaceful now listen to what he says
about the actual peaceful protest
outside the supreme court justice's home
yet the corporate media and democrats
slander them with the the made-up term
insurrection they are insurrection
in this instance that they are look look
at what oh my god look at this on the
side on the street
they took children sidewalk chalk
and they drew hangers on the street how
dare they oh my god what violence is
ensuing
the violence
that happens when people get their hands
on some children's sidewalk chalk
get the [ __ ] out of here with this
instance that they are not willing to
call off their goons
even now even now as this has the
potential to escalate and escalate
further
goons goons look what i wrote i wrote
[Applause]
we gonna goon you like a [ __ ]
ted cruz we are gonna goon you like a
[ __ ]
speaking speaking of uh goons uh welcome
welcome uh gabe sanchez
uh welcome thank you thank you yeah well
i'm you know are you a goon are you
gooning this morning dude i'm i love the
goonies
right are you good and all that dude i'm
gonna you should see me dude the whole
the whole morning i've been spending
just riding
in sidewalk chalk
up and down the street
oh okay okay okay did you hear did you
hear um
did you hear this story maybe we'll get
to it later i think i got a message here
about the uh the gmail the gmail is woke
have you seen this oh yeah ronnie
jackson yeah man i didn't know this i
didn't know this and later maybe uh
we'll have to call tech support because
my gmail is all [ __ ] up now like i got
my spam filter all [ __ ] up it's it's
crazy oh yeah yeah i i have some friends
who work out okay good good maybe they
might be able to connect me okay good
maybe maybe later we'll uh and i think
that's what that private message was
about it's later we'll we'll get the uh
we'll get the good um so you are see you
are a goon right you are
straight sidewalk jack goon goonan
yeah well maybe maybe we should start a
gang called the chalk the the chalk
goons or something i don't know come up
with a name folks
oh my god this is ridiculous right yeah
this is crazy the ted cruz tucker
carlson the contraception chalkers i
don't know hey that's pretty good the
condom chalkers the condom chalkers it
could be the condom chalkers for
for men contraception shockers for women
or just you know in general
whatever what right you know so our
you know
women
are from nars
right that's right do we establish that
they're from nars they're from ours yeah
that was that was a couple weeks ago we
found out
that was last week last week i don't i
can't keep track of this [ __ ] man
someone could tell me what day and time
it is
that would be good that would be great
that would be great if we could because
right now you know what i might have to
contact tech support because i feel like
my my google calendar is off well it
might be it might be because you know
gabe today is traitor day i i mean uh
confederate memorial day right yeah
losing traders day yeah yeah
what do you think about uh
i think it's south carolina i don't know
how many other states um are alabama
over this great holiday kentucky has one
oh my god uh of course those are the
ones that i know probably tennessee if i
had to get yeah i mean they're trying to
marry children why would they celebrate
traders
what is this
what is confederate because you because
i sent this to you this morning you're
like is this real i'm like yeah yeah
yeah it's real it's [ __ ] real that
they're like yay our heritage of our our
grandpa happy owning other human beings
different
instead of because you know states
rights uh different states it's wrong
that's what we said this morning states
wrongs states wrong each state has a
different day of remembrance so
okay so today is south carolina's
memorial day is that what you're saying
yeah yeah okay so it's alabama
mississippi south carolina
kentucky florida north carolina texas
tennessee of course all the people who
just can't move on it was formally
recognized in georgia louisiana and
virginia several states celebrated near
april 26th when the last major
confederate field army surrendered at
bennett place north carolina agency like
they literally are they literally are
celebrating they're they're [ __ ]
losing like they're not even celebrating
a win during the war
and then they're like
this day
we need to celebrate
their we need to take pride in the fact
that we
we lost our right to own other human
beings we lost the fight against human
rights and it's ridiculous that we
should memorialize it it makes it it
makes no sense and here's why january
19th texas the fourth monday in april is
alabama and florida uh it's like it's
all over the map in other words last
monday in april is uh
is mississippi
may 10th is north carolina and south
carolina june 3rd is kentucky and
tennessee i mean this is what happens
when you ban books people you can't
figure out what dates to use what do you
get you actually lost they you're right
you know what they lost like they can't
even figure it out i feel like we should
call tech support for them to figure out
what their google calendar's like
because they can't line up what day it
was even though the fact that they they
they surrendered
on uh around april 26th
in in 1865. but here we are 2022 and
they're like yeah we'll go january
we'll go the fourth monday in april
we'll go the last monday in april we'll
go
we'll go june 3rd
let's put the calendar on the wall and
just throw a dart and see where it lands
they've been celebrating this for 156
years wait a second wait a second who is
they which state the losers well i know
uh let's see in the spring of 1866 uh
the ladies memorial association in
colombia so like literally the year
after they lost they're like yay it's
been a year since we lost
they passed a resolution to set aside
one day annualized to memorialize the
confederate war dead
um
[ __ ] those traitors really honest i mean
do we do we do we celebrate um the dead
of the nazi army do we celebrate that
does anyone really commemorate i mean
besides a bunch of fascists i mean maybe
the ones that are down in florida i i
guess so the ones in front of the the
the disney world sign
whatever right well i mean i mean they
are desantis supporters i mean it's very
clear to safely assume even i mean well
i actually i know this uh
germany is like no no no no no no no no
no no we are not doing that [ __ ] right
we're trying to remove that we listen
guys we really [ __ ] up and we
wanna make sure that we don't make this
mistake again
uh and
we might have people in america and you
might have people you know in the world
that are like oh you know and you know
they're like [ __ ] you know lubin and
tube and working and jerking they're
[ __ ] getting off on this
nick
is one of them oh yeah exactly but for
the most part
most sane logical good people
do not try to live in the past and
memorialize
what happened during world war ii right
in the holocaust and everything well you
know i'm not saying really honestly i'm
not saying that that people in south
carolina or alabama or texas shouldn't
have a holiday and shouldn't get a day
off and shut down the government for a
day that sounds that sounds all fair and
good yeah but they shouldn't call it
confederate memorial day
maybe they should call it like america
day or um we we lost day or week one
because really they won
yeah if you think about it the
confederacy
and in all its in all its own glory
they lost the war but they really did
win because gabe they got to rejoin the
union abraham lincoln let them those
traitors rejoin the union yeah right
they tried to they tried to be like yo
we're going to secede we're going to
leave
and then they got a second chance right
and they would have failed and even with
their second chance they really [ __ ]
it up because right after the civil war
everyone knows that um the right to vote
was extended to to black men um and then
and then segregation happened because
the south was like well we may not be
able to own you
but we definitely gonna make you think
that we [ __ ] own you you are not
going to have any part of our society
and that's when segregation started and
that again this is the
the [ __ ] that we have to go through
when we're talking about you know
knowing your actual [ __ ] history
because they're celebrating lies is what
they're celebrating they're not
celebrating the [ __ ] truth here right
if they were actually celebrating the
truth they wouldn't have confederate
memorial day i'm not saying that
tennessee or alabama or louisiana or
georgia or florida or south carolina
shouldn't have a state holiday i'm all
for holidays hell yeah barbecue eat some
food hell it's [ __ ] taco tuesday go
eat some goddamn tacos
on freedom day or whatever the hell you
want to call it yeah i don't know
but this idea that we have to continue
to placate to these [ __ ] these
snowflake ass these snowflake ass
confederacy these people who capitulate
to the confederacy this idea that
somehow it's a great heritage that your
grandpappy fought for the right to own
human beings right i mean that's
literally what we're talking about here
that you're grant you are proud of your
heritage that your
grandpappy fought for the right to own
other human beings all the while in the
backdrop
the supreme court bought and paid for by
the same people who love to celebrate
confederate day
the same people who love to celebrate
states rats and they that's wrongs
and and the cheeto dust confederacy
they're taking away women's rights like
as we speak that's the goal and they're
terrified of sidewalk chalk
um yeah
which is you know i i i've heard you
know uh
people are many people are saying hey
super chat
uh
many people are saying
that uh sidewalk chalk is the
this is
a is a pretty pretty strong weapon right
right should we have should we have
sidewalk chalk regulation gabe now that
we know that they're it's very violent
and dangerous i mean should we make sure
that i feel like we should we have
background checks universal background
we should hire a team of investigators
to do an independent oh my gosh study on
the traffic effects of sidewalk chalk on
democracy right
[Music]
[Laughter]
mj says state's wrongs she's she's
taking your leader let me apologize for
normal uh floridians we do exist like
the unsexy m m's thank you thank you mj
for the super chat um all the m m's are
equally sexy you just want to put that
on there so here and that's what i'm
trying to say about like states getting
a holiday is that like most people in
these states are like
you know i'm it's a state holiday the
banks are closed you know it's kind of
gross but
you know what if right like but we don't
have to do that anymore we don't have to
placate and you know not offend the the
fascist we don't we can offend them it
is time it is now time to speak out and
offend these people just like drawing
[ __ ] coat hangers and riding on susan
collins sidewalk right with children's
chalk is offending is offensive it's
offensive that you would write such
offensive words like stick to your
promise dudes and collins that's why we
elected you i mean literally they wrote
let me see if i can bring this up when i
originally heard of this story and
somebody mentioned it to me i was like
uh i kind of hope it's just
hopscotch like i know i kind of just
bunch of squares it literally pretty
much is right and so now i'm thinking
maybe
for those you know um people who are
pro-democracy maybe you should just draw
hopscotch squares with messages
of pro-democracy uh movements
inside the squares right look at this
look at this language here look at this
language here gabe to overthrow
susan collins
idea this one's kind of aggressive if i
have to do this i mean it's pretty
it's pretty violent here yeah it says
susie please the violent word of please
yeah asking nicely is definitely
definitely violent uh mainers want
because this is in maine very well
doesn't know mainers want
w-h-p-a which stands for women's health
protection act which would codify yeah
what we know as roe v wade or or the
protections that roe v wade and the
rights that women are afforded through
roe v wade
um it would codify that and i believe it
says um at the end here what does it say
it says
um
i forget what it actually says but this
is pretty threatening uh hoodlum says
here i'm very concerned
i'm very concerned about the
neighborhood vandals and thugs
threatening me susan collins probably
he says r from moscow oh yeah for sure
for sure
she actually called the cops over this
chalk they caught they called the cops
what do you think the cops were like i
would love to and maybe this is a video
i would love to see what the
cops
like it's a crime like it's a csi intro
kind of thing right where you get the
like
uh
you know sunglasses off it's like yeah
you know it's like that kinda
yeah and it's just a bunch of you know
uh clips of things from maine which is
just like a bunch of forestry right
right right
and he's apparently a really pretty
state i mean yeah yeah no yeah and i'm
people i'm sorry for uh susan collins
who um oh i mean i'm sorry for all the
voters there you know you know the the
great part about maine gabe did you know
this um a lot of people talked about in
our chat before ranked choice voting are
you are you aware
did you know maine has ranked choice
voting
i did not know that yes that main main
and i believe in some of their elections
has rank choice voting um
and and
to be fair to be fair to uh uh you know
election integrity susan collins was
re-elected on lies but they did re-elect
her with ranked choice voting
see that's that's the so it's flawed
well i mean i mean democracy is flawed
you know i mean i mean that's that's the
whole point it'll never be perfect well
right i mean that's the whole point like
the whole actual point of democracy
is to have flaws because we need to see
these flaws like we see in susan collins
susan collins is a [ __ ] liar she lies
to her constituents now hopefully that
flaw will
flawless flawless way out above
eventually but i and i don't know what
maine's recall
i'm not really sure what their recall
laws are for their elections but maybe
there's maybe there's uh mainers um
could actually
use the recall laws to recall susan
collins as well because you know that's
a flaw in democracy sometimes
um you know the politicians aren't what
they say they are and you choose the
wrong one even with a great system like
ranked choice voting right and and that
that's the beauty though folks of
democracy the beauty is is this this
sidewalk chalk here who which apparently
washed away um in the next ring can you
imagine that gabe oh
my god so you're telling me that when
the cops showed up
they're like
so do we find any trace evidence of the
chalk and they're like i'm sorry sir do
you think they fingerprinted anything i
i wanna believe that they they like
dusted for prince and they're like no no
you're ruining the evidence and he's
like no i'm looking for prince he's like
yeah it's chalk you guys it's dust it's
[ __ ] dust you're dusting the dust
and then and so he's like are there any
uh trace evidence of the chalk and
they're like uh well sir uh there's
about a uh
68 humidity right now and there was a a
light due on the ground and of course
there's been people walking across it so
the the original message isn't quite
intact but we've got some trace
particles here you know uh we found it
to be it was uh it was a crayola chalk
uh it's only sold game brand [ __ ]
name brand not that dollar store no no
no because they went they went all in on
their weaponry their website and their
armory was was [ __ ] what the person
had to act armor yeah the person who who
who wrote this and in in uh you know
offered the supplies which was probably
funded through george soros
was the name brand [ __ ] man you know
[ __ ] crayola dog reason why these
these violent these violent uh
pro-women's um rights people this the
violence of writing in chalk of course
it's funded by george this type of
violence would be funded by george soros
is why they could go get the brand name
um uh sidewalk chalk not that dollar
store [ __ ] no no that is because you
need something that you know that you
can you can take a solid solid movement
up and down and diagonal right you can't
you can't you can't create violence with
sidewalk chalk if it's breaking off and
it's not cooperating and it's not you
can't you're like what type of what type
of message does that send yeah oh you
couldn't even you couldn't even write
the word out you could this is the same
people 101 type [ __ ] folks come on guys
you got it you got to make sure you get
the crayola brand chalk exactly here you
can't get that dollar store [ __ ] when
you're really trying to create good
trouble this is antifa 101 well maybe
antipa 102 type stuff right yeah we're
we're moving right it's kind of involved
in the courses it's kind of advanced you
know when you're when you're
when you're writing
on a sidewalk with sidewalk chalk this
is [ __ ] this is [ __ ] ridiculous
and the only reason why i'm spending
time clowning these people
is because they're they're frightened
gabe they're absolutely absolutely right
so frightened that they're making up
stories about the supreme court justices
moving out of town did you hear about
this oh i heard it was that jesse waters
i don't know
yeah someone said someone said that they
had to move out of town which is a
[ __ ] lie right and then it spread
around the internet oh my god they're
having to move out of that but they they
quote all the [ __ ] people who right
who the to the gqp has had the force to
go into hiding yeah because they
threatened him because they're
socialists radicals i mean jesus christ
we we've had people on this show that
have had to go into hiding a little bit
because of threats right because of what
they believe yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
it's it's it's insanity just remember
that when you when you come after
someone you know fascist especially
misogynist sexist you know bigots
whatever the first thing instead of
using logic or reasoning to say hey this
is my belief and this is why i believe
you're wrong the first thing that they
will do is attack you they will attack
you personally they will try to dox you
they will try to reveal something
embarrassing about you they will try to
distract from the actual topic of
discussion the actual problem that's
that's that's being discussed and
they'll go oh well you're you're fat or
you're ugly or or you you know you you
live in this area or here's your address
you know like it's those types of things
where it'd say well i can't beat you i
can't actually debate you on this so you
know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna just
throw some [ __ ] on the wall and see what
sticks and i'm going to get a bunch of
people to go after and smear that [ __ ]
on the walls just like at the capitol
right that's what it is
here here is uh
jerry says
i'm calling the police because susan
collins
you might as well just like just call
the police just because of shoes and
collins yeah
well i just i i just i'm i am now
running this video idea of susan collins
calling the cops or rather the cops
showing up to the crime scene in my head
uh so
look out i think a video will be coming
soon that's good that's good yeah that's
good people in the in the comments are
saying what about the violence in
wisconsin where where where uh the
bugaloo boy types through a molotov
cocktail to an anti-abortion clinic i
mean that's what we're gonna find out
like all the all the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that they that they conflate just like
they're conflating people peacefully
protesting getting loud in front of a a
supreme court justice's home and riding
in on on sidewalks with chalk
just like they conflate that with the
violent insurrection to try to overthrow
our government and install a dictator
they conflated black lives matter with
the insurrection which we know that all
the fires and all that [ __ ] bugaloo boys
have been convicted they they and they
were found to be guilty of starting a
lot of that violence starting a lot of
the fires you're not fooling us anymore
yeah we know we're not going to be
fooled by this nonsense by this antifa
exist antifa that's why we're clowning
you yeah yeah if you're in the comments
saying that [ __ ] stay around stick
around maybe you'll learn a few things
yeah because if you want to see
something that actually is happening
that is affecting real people right
watch this doctor and this is in a
tennessee women's clinic um
i believe let's see the doctor's name
is um
i don't have it handy here it's hard to
see on his i think it's campbell i
believe is his his name um this is a
report from cnn fake news um but cnn
this is communist news network
ron desantis would say and did you see
his little ronda sanchez's little oh my
god commies are gonna take over the
world or something or i don't know no i
figured that's like a that's like an
everyday thing he wakes up it comes to
take it off of the world and then he's
like i'm gonna have my
my my uh my bowl of mush right well i
mean he won't he won't um
put a pause on gas tax in florida
because the gas prices are so high you
want to know why your gas prices are so
high in florida it ain't because of joe
biden because ron desantis is uh is
holding up the i don't know he's some
kind of fascist bill he wants his he
wants to or he'll reject the
infrastructure but then try to take
credit for the infrastructure and the
funds that come to florida absolutely
absolutely so let's listen to the
question that this doctors asked again
this is a women's clinic
in tennessee are you going to start
telling your patients
i don't know
um
i don't know that any of us know
so that is if you look here
dr aaron campbell
of knoxville center of reproductive
health now this this is
you know this is the [ __ ] they do
because they act like this this guy's
this guy's the enemy you know they they
murdered dr tiller do you remember the
story of doctor dr tiller was that which
assassination were they that's right
inside of a church and it's yeah i'm in
a church right right yeah yep yep they
can't that that the almighty christians
came in a church to murder someone you
know there's that
what is the commandment thing what is
that there's a there's one of us there's
ten
there's ten there are ten of them but
there is one that says something
specifically about um
i don't know killing someone or
something like that oh but anyways thou
shall not kill yeah well that's a pretty
big one
it would be tough for these christians
to actually believe
um what
what anything is in the [ __ ] book
that they hold sacred um but here
aaron campbell is a doctor of
reproductive health now
um i told the story the personal story
of my wife um getting her iud or
contraception removed
at a women's health clinic that we were
trying
trying to have another baby and a lot of
people that go to the knoxville center
reproductive health are probably
trying to have children
not not not not trying to right you know
make sure that their clump of cells is
okay or not yeah but they're trying to
have a columbus cells they're trying to
make a baby or even or even so they had
a baby and they've come to the clinic
for help or guidance or support right
right because you look at everything
else and then republicans say you got to
have the baby but we're not going to
offer you we're not going to fund
clinics we're not going to give you
programs we're not going to educate you
on how to raise a child they're just
going to say good luck and go [ __ ]
yourselves right because a lot of these
clinics that they want to demonize that
they want to close down
because they believe in health and
medical treatment and science and
especially for the for women and the
women's right to
to have their own choice of their
medical decisions over their body
that's what he's saying here he's not
talking about abortion he's talking
about his patience
in general like
in general him
giving advice to his patients in general
yeah is is now an up in question
it's not just about abortion folks
it's not just about about what your
religious beliefs are this is about
women's medical decisions and access
to health care that may save their lives
and may
actually create more children and give
them the ability to bear
a child you [ __ ] boneheads this is
absolutely
ridiculous i i can't even believe we're
in 2022 and we're having to have this
discussion but i'm i'm i i'm i'm kind of
glad that
um
maybe or maybe not jeannie thomas
actually released this
um leaked this decision that's that's
what some people are saying yeah some
people you know i don't know if it was
her or was clearance or right well i i
actually i actually think these people
who are going on and on about the leak
are going to be very disappointed with
who actually leaked this um and they're
going to be they're going to be they're
not going to talk about
exactly they're not going to talk
they're not even what leak what are you
talking about who's leaked what you know
it's crazy gas isn't a discussion
anymore right uh the border really isn't
a discussion anymore these things have a
way of uh just like poof just like you
know just like the chalk on the sidewalk
they just kind of wash away wash away
and then they decide is a problem when
they need it to be
but
i guess the point was is that i'm kind
of glad
that they did this early that that
whoever leaked this thought it was a
good idea to let people know their
victory because i at first i thought
well maybe this was a a quote-unquote
liberal or someone who's pro-women
and pro-women's rights was leaking this
early to make sure that the coalition
had time right to gather and to coalesce
with weeks of advance notice of this
decision
but then i got to thinking no no there's
there's
what actually happened was is they were
so [ __ ] excited so excited that they
finally got to take away women's rights
right they finally got to show women in
this country that they do not give a
[ __ ]
about them or their liberty they were so
excited that they couldn't hold it any
longer they were so getting free like
we're going to re-ejaculation oh yeah i
know there i'm yeah it's it's the i'm
gonna quote
i'm gonna quote amy coney barrett i'm
gonna quote brett kavanaugh i'm going to
quote you know the domestic supplied
infants i'm going to quote
uh
the
the medieval
uh
case of of a witch like
um
or you know the the
yeah it's just
it isn't saying that in 2022 that's what
we have going on right and i i look at
that and i see
such excitement
and obviously you know the inevitable
truth is yes it probably will be
overturned unless something crazy
happens and
an opinion or a judgment of one of these
justices is is reversed i don't know if
that'll happen
but
i do
look at it and i agree with you i
completely agree that you know somebody
on the right was like oh yeah whether it
was a clerk or somebody like somebody
here's the thing i don't know if it was
intentionally done from the justice or
if it was more along the lines of a
right wing clerk was like oh yeah [ __ ]
women you know and then they're like
let's do some laps he's like i'm gonna
show you how we [ __ ] own the libs
and then they released it and then of
course they're like we're gonna
investigate
and now
i mean they've got a few different
agencies that are on this case actually
which i'm like
oh my god why why waste your time with
who leaked a decision that's going to
come down anyways when you could
actually investigate the the
planning and plotting of an insurrection
of a supreme court justice wife and if
he had anything to do with it which
seems he did because he did vote in the
way of instruction speaking speaking of
insurrectionist
um
porno holly here you know he's really
he's really pro pro anti-porn you notice
that like he is yeah he is very
strangely pro anti-porn like yeah he's
almost obsessed with
like obsessed with talking about points
right obsessed well and during the the
uh katanji brown jackson hearings he was
obsessed with child porn which is even a
little more sus did you see that video
where he contacted tech support about i
did i did maybe we should you know i i
am still having problems with my gmail
we might have to after the uh break here
here in just uh five minutes or so we
may have to get tech support online for
my gmail it's it's acting up again it
seems like the spam filter is off but uh
josh and pro anti-porn holly here
and what up is this his wife is that
what they're saying here i think i i
believe
well
you know his wife or his vessel whatever
right well you know yeah she is she is
obviously when you're married to uh a
fascist uh anti-woman um white male like
beautiful beautiful earth and vessel
right that's been you definitely
you know anointed by the almighty god
maybe maybe fox news gets her title
right and calls her
an earthen vessel here like she's
wearing red and it kind of looks like a
handmaid's tale
you're saying it's like the transition
she doesn't want to use she doesn't have
to you know wear the hat yet or anything
like that but she's moving into the
wardrobe
so so you guys remember i don't know
when this was but there were some
protesters that came outside their home
and was getting loud on the sidewalk
gabe they got they got really loud like
they were yelling
they were yelling and and it was it was
scary that they were yelling because i
mean this is outside their hugs
he calls them thugs but this was well
this was uh uh months ago months ago oh
right it wasn't where he it wasn't the
state he represents right
no no no no not he doesn't live in
missouri right right it was in d.c it
was in virginia virginia yeah i believe
they live in virginia i just want to
make sure it wasn't the state that he's
faking to be from but no but he called
them he called them thugs he called them
thugs and i think it was after it was
after the insurrection that this
happened um i believe so and he called
them thugs and what he meant was was
black people they showed right to his
sidewalk and they were they were
very loudly right sounds about white um
and his earthen vessel here or his wife
as we would refer to her he would
probably refer to as his earth and
vessel um she she got she got very mad
and upset and called the cops and josh
hawley actually made a big scene public
scene about it out these uh these
quote-unquote thugs showed up and by
again when you say thugs he means black
people showed up at his house but let's
let's listen to their experience and how
it is compared
to other folks showing up to other folks
sidewalks and being very loud and
writing writing with sidewalk jock let's
listen start with you this has got to be
like deja vu all over again oh my god oh
no
yeah you know
from the left is really unbelievable i
mean
the ptsd is intense i can't even i can't
even move past the hypocrisy can we just
play that can we just play that part
right over again yeah yeah well how far
you want to go ahead just when you i
just want to hear him say it again yeah
you know the hypocrisy from the left is
really unbelievable i mean
you know what's unbelievable you're a
fake outrage that's what's unbelievable
that right it i mean completely you
can't believe a single goddamn word
right this [ __ ] bonehead says i mean
it i don't know this is
why why pretend
that what happened to you and what
happened here is violent
why pretend right why pretend that you
were so frightened and you're so scared
when literally you were pumping your
fist
for trump supporters to beat and kill
cops to overthrow our constitution
like he was pumping his fist he was
really proud of that like nazi kind of
proud yeah let's listen and here we have
the white house encouraging people to go
out and to engage in what amounts to
harassment which by the way now that
that is actually
a false statement because i will push
back on jin saki when she says that the
the in the bite administration when they
say do not go and protest in front of
justice's house bull [ __ ] [ __ ] if you
are legally there and you are peacefully
protesting you do that goon type [ __ ]
all day long [ __ ] that [ __ ] if he's
gonna bring up if he's gonna bring up
the federal
uh uh a mandate that says you cannot do
that that's what he's gonna do here
right now he'll say that and he's gonna
lie yeah yeah and my counterpoint is you
have to show intent here's the thing
what people don't realize
is that
there are five
people
on the on the bench right now on the
supreme court who are going to overturn
roe v wade right you would have to
overturn you'd have to get someone like
gorsuch maybe
maybe or or roberts to to say okay you
know i'll i'll flip i do not see that
happening the only reason you could say
this is illegal and the reason that you
have not seen cops arrest people
and block off the homes is because
the likelihood of an intent to reverse
someone's opinion to force someone to
change their mind is incredibly unlikely
with a conservative heavy court it is
not going to happen
right but peacefully protesting is not
it's not evidence of change
yeah you're on the public sidewalk
peacefully protesting you're not a mob
you're not a bunch of thugs you like you
showed the the tucker carlson clip
earlier it's literally people standing
[ __ ] still right holding a banner
with the megaphone and everyone else is
standing watching and listening and
holding candles right they're being
really they have fire game they have
fire and they have sidewalk chalk god
damn it look they're they're drawing
hangers on the street man okay look
they may not be tiki torches
but
they're candles
and sure yeah you want to be threatened
by a little like soy candle from bed
bath and beyond so be it your goddamn
snowflake soy soy boys okay
i i just come up with a theory okay i
want to play the rest of this clip
and and maybe maybe this conspiracy
theory that i'm gonna spout out here
makes sense to some maybe it doesn't but
let's let's listen to the rest of this
clip and i'll i'll give you my my
conspiracy theory here is illegal
federal law says that you cannot picket
or protest or harass justices with the
point with the purpose of trying to
change their vote in a case that is not
true you can pick it you can protest
that is [ __ ]
i had a bunch of people that came into
my comments yesterday after i made that
tweet which was like oh republicans say
uh you know you they're barbaric you
can't be outside the house but then also
republicans are the same people that are
like listen your [ __ ] and hang pen right
you know right like like yeah but i had
a bunch of federal property let's
destroy federal property which is an
actual crime right yeah you you broke in
and you you broke like breaking and
entering that's b and e that's already a
crime right there and then you uh
threaten people's lives uh you had the
intent to commit murder right uh and you
also injured uh people you know there
were there were uh
side effects of what happened through
ptsd
emotional trauma physical trauma i mean
jesus christ some of those cops had
heart attacks because they were beating
them so hard right i mean
here here is here is cop killer josh
holly well i mean he's pro cop killer
right josh hawley josh hawley talking
about federal statutes and criminal
statutes get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] let's listen to what else this
bonet has to say and then i'll give you
my theory and that's exactly what they
are doing but yeah unfortunately uh
we've been on the receiving end of that
uh we know what it's like aaron who was
home alone with our baby girl when uh a
bunch of thugs showed up at our house
and bunch of thugs he means black people
folks that's what he means that's code
for black
people the elders when she asked him to
leave they didn't they came up to the
house pounded on the doors and
ultimately were charged with trespass
but here's the deal you cannot give in
to these people you cannot give an inch
when they come at you you gotta
he's always talking about giving inches
he really is obsessed with with uh these
phrases that could be construed with his
his obsession and
his you know he might have won he might
have some sort of like inferiority
complex or something or like he's seen a
lot of well-endowed men and the porn
research he's done and now he's like oh
god how do i stack up you know i can
barely kiss my wife on the lips right
right well he's not his wife i mean he
calls his wife yeah his earth invests i
mean it's like it looks like this it's
like
oh i can't touch her
lips
it's not a digital model um so here's my
theory gabe yeah that maybe maybe the
reason why
that you know because these [ __ ] do
almost anything to get one one moment on
fox news like they'll create this whole
narrative to get on fox news and say the
same thing over and over and over again
that it's against the law for people to
protest like they're going to try to say
that it's against the law for the left
to peacefully protest here that's what
they're saying
why wouldn't they why wouldn't they go
to the extent of leaking
leaking this decision knowing knowing
full well that the left is going to
protest and then call because they're pr
because
this has never really happened in our
history where a decision was leaked
ahead of time so there was no way there
was no way for the public to know what
the supreme court is thinking that's why
the statute exists and that's why they
keep these things under wraps
it's so that you don't have the
capability of people protesting or
picketing to try to change the justice's
decision that's the whole point maybe
just maybe
someone decided that it was a good idea
to trigger that so that way they could
call peaceful protest illegal oh yeah
that way they could break up the priests
will protest as illegal
i mean i'm just saying this theory just
because josh hawley goes on fox news and
says it
makes a lot of sense that this is why
it's almost like they want to take away
your first amendment right well i mean
if you're if you're standing around
wondering why they're always complaining
about the freedom of speech it means why
why
why don't can't we stop other people's
freedom of speech right that's what
they're saying that's what sounds like a
fascist to me well
there is there are a bunch of fascists
and apparently
did you hear about this google is
suppressing fascist emails apparently
did you i did a story i did hear this
story i did i did i heard i did what's
ronnie up to here when he can't figure
out what a spam builder is do you
can you can this guy is a doctor and
also a sitting politician
he is like he is a member of congress
isn't that crazy like the man the man
was in the navy right uh and he got
his medical degree
uh and then
you know he was like hey i'm gonna run
for office which i guess is really no
achievement these days considering the
people that have been running over
the green man yet right yeah margaret
yeah exactly
uh
but
you know i look at it and i'm like
oh man this guy is is
incredibly incompetent whenever you see
him donald trump's like uh ronnie
jackson and he's like at the bar with
like a a glass like he's always in the
back of the room
at a party at mar-a-lago and he's like
yeah
wow he's the guy who said trump was the
most fit president ever right we're
supposed to believe
that ronnie jackson he i mean i don't
think it's far-fetched to believe this
that ronnie jackson does not know how to
run a spam filter because he doesn't
know how to run a scale like he couldn't
weigh donald trump to the right weight i
mean we all know that the weight that he
said publicly is a bunch of [ __ ]
right i mean there's just no [ __ ] way
so he runs he runs his spam builder
right he runs a scale when he's when
he's measuring people's weight but
ronnie jackson says gmail is actively
suppressing emails from republicans from
hitting your inbox
straight to spam he says
this is election interference big tech
is out of control literally he has no
idea no [ __ ] clue
why these are going to spam he has no
idea no like well i'm hoping i'm hoping
here uh we should take a break i'm gonna
find out if i can get in contact with a
buddy at google and see if he can
connect me with their customer support
um
so just give me a few minutes and maybe
i can make that happen if not then okay
that's fine let's take a break before we
go to break i want to read
eric swalwell's he says this gmail
do you see it in the room right now
ronnie jackson is terrified of gmail and
and gabe again my gmail is acting up so
maybe this is a good thing you will have
uh your your friend from tech support
from google so everyone stick around
right after the break um we're gonna get
tech support online to try to fix my
gmail we'll be right back after these
messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy
by the time we reached dc we was 50
strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow
so we can circle the city again
years bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lib
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong
wipe your ass at least once a day
ears
tammy
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
hopefully we can get tech support on the
line here
my gmail is spamming out
as you know ronnie jackson's gmail has
been completely out of control
causing election interference look at
this [ __ ]
this is what he's been saying
he tweeted this
gmail is actively suppressing emails
from republicans
are from republicans from this is weird
how he says this gmail is actively
suppressing emails from republicans from
hitting your inbox
i don't want them to hit my inbox i
don't want it i mean it really honestly
if google and gmail is this good at
suppressing republican emails that's the
[ __ ] email that i want in the first
place
i mean that's the way i see it
like i want to make sure that this [ __ ]
is not getting into my inbox i do not
want your fascist nonsense
to infiltrate my inbox
like you want to infiltrate women's
bodies i just don't i'm not into that i
just really don't and no nope the
craziest part about this
is he uses he uses all caps like trump
does you see this like he's been he's
really been drinking the kool-aid way
too [ __ ] long ronnie
ronnie you really need to lay off the
[ __ ] trump kool-aid
i mean he's he puts spam in all caps
election interference isn't all caps
here
and big tech is out of control and he
gets the the um
the nice um you know big tech in there
you got to get that you got to get the
the
the buzzword big tick because i wonder i
wonder
if uh hunter biden's laptop
has the gmail app installed i'm sure
and we'll finally get a statement from
hunter biden's laptop eventually
if the
if the gmail app
is installed natively on hunter biden's
laptop now as you know
speaking 100 biden's laptop that's
probably why my gmail is all jacked up i
got an email from george soros from
hunter biden's laptop
[Music]
and apparently hunter biden's laptop is
making some news this morning
um i tweeted it out and you guys if i
tweet something that says breaking
you know that it has to be it has to be
100 percent fact checked um breaking
hunter biden's laptop reveals the
coordinates of its charging cord
uh so and
we'll see that hunter biden's laptop
will reveal
the coordinates of how it is charged um
and maybe maybe maybe we'll just find
out
if the gmail app
uh that that pesky liberal libtard
gmail app the radical socialist soros
gmail app
if it's natively
if it's natively installed on hunter
biden's laptop
um i think i think uh gabe's got tech
support let's see do we got him on the
line here let's see
let me see if we got um tech support on
the line here
um
tech support and and i'm looking for
some tech support i think gabe was
supposed to get you on the line hello
yeah uh sir what's your name
uh james what's up james are you with
google tech support i am yeah and i'm
having some a horrible time with my spam
filter
um
it really is it really is suppressing a
lot of like spam emails like it's it's
putting the spam emails the junk emails
in the spam folder i'm not sure why it's
doing that is there a reason why google
would make sure that spam emails junk
emails would go into a spam builder i'm
really confused
yeah yeah yeah uh what do you know do
you know what the uh the emails are that
they're they're coming from do you know
the messages that are well
really the messaging is them is to um to
grift
um their supporters it's the republicans
who are sending out constantly
um these emails that are trying to grift
money away from their supporters and
they're they're really piling up in my
spam inbox i'm not sure why they're
going there but
yeah we've actually uh
listen we have a whole team dedicated to
this um we found that during the you
know leading up to the 2020 election
post 2020 election we've had a lot of
people coming in and getting a
bit inundated with uh with the requests
to solve their spam issue turns out that
a majority we're looking at 98 of emails
that are sent are actually coming from
trump-related uh uh domains
oh yeah okay now when you say spam
related issues you know it kind of makes
me hungry i don't know do you guys do
that are you guys aware that the word
spam is the same as the canned meat are
you guys aware of that because that
seems like a really
bad problem when it starts to trend on
the internet well yeah i mean we
actually we actually have uh
different different dishes in the in the
cafeteria they're pretty good um yeah oh
it really is yeah spam one of them do
you guys serve spam sandwiches we do
make spam jokes
it's fried spam with rice wrapped in
seaweed it's actually pretty good oh
well it is good
right so it's so it's a lettuce wrap is
what you're saying of course it's not
quite a lot of strap but i mean you know
seaweed is different than lettuce but i
mean that's neither here nor there you
called about getting help with your
uh your spam issue right well i mean i
have a lot of spam issues i have the
gmail spam issue and i have the spam
issue of how you cook spam i mean that's
what i'm saying maybe you guys should
consider changing the name of the
the junk mail folder and from spam to
something different it's kind of
confusing to some of these people i mean
especially like ronnie jackson have you
heard the news of
ronnie jackson he's really got you guys
in the news this morning
yeah we've uh we've been getting a lot
of messages from ronnie jackson we keep
telling him to properly contact us via
email you know okay how is he contacting
you has he uh he is just sending faxing
you or something letters too oh oh so
he's snail mailing yeah he is he is
faxing our our uh our our
uh welcome desk
so he's spamming he's spamming your your
welcome this with facts
yes yeah yeah yeah which is you know
obviously ironic but right well uh yeah
like i said we have a whole team
dedicated this because he's taking up so
much of our time trying to deal with it
we keep trying to tell him you know
obviously we're like listen call us at
this number right send us this email uh
he just keeps trying to send in
handwritten letters
telling did he write him on does he
write him with a sharpie like his um his
mango no no
it looks like they're written in crayon
but like not like crayola crayon it
looks like they're like dollar store
crown
it looks like the message had been
broken up so when he was writing it
broke up so the words are kind of messed
up so you're you know
trying to make sense of it but yeah he
writes him and then he faxes them over
you know and again we you know we keep
telling them you know email us you guys
still have a fax machine there
we have a bank max machine and all the
google we have one fax machine google
still have the fax machine and really
it's only a printer you know but it has
the facts i got you i see so so like you
receive your faxes in an actual email
and yeah so what you're saying is when
ronnie faxes you it goes to a spam
folder that is the fax machine email and
then you have to print them out to make
them the physical yeah yeah like i said
we have a whole team dedicated is where
97 98 of the emails that are coming
through are trump related
and ronnie jackson
doesn't seem to understand how to follow
directions and we're trying to make it
as simple as possible we're trying to
tell them look these are the steps in
which you can um you know uh make sure
that these
these emails are not going to your spam
folder what what are those ways if if
you were to describe to a buffoon or
doofus like ronnie jackson how to make
sure if you want if you want your
republican propaganda not to end up in
your spam
junk mail boxes is there specific
directions that you could give to a
doofus like ronnie jackson that would
understand yeah easily um we actually
you know implemented some of the stuff
because of ronnie jackson oh okay go to
if you go on the left-hand side you
navigate down to what the area that is
located it says spam you know there's a
little like stop sign with an
exclamation point it says spam right
there you'll see the list of emails that
come through now
what you also see is the ability to
delete them you could delete a bulk
right because people don't want to have
to select through every single one they
just select all and delete but you also
can look at the email and you can mark
as not spam right
i see you know the thing that is going
to happen
is um you can't stop everyone else from
marking it as spam you know so what do
you mean by that you mean you mean if
the republicans spread their propaganda
around in all these email boxes and all
those people market spam it still might
end up in your spam folder is that what
you're saying exactly exactly okay so
because people are marking it spam
because it is spam because it is
republican russian propaganda it becomes
that's how you guys are classifying into
spam because your users are
know that it's spam so you're saying
just to give a real world example let's
say you get a lot of i don't know like
credit card applications and junk mail
in your in your in your mailbox you're
saying basically what you can do
is write on the letter and send it back
to the sender saying hey
this is spam i don't want it and they
and you stop sending it is that what
you're saying can we you're saying
you're saying via email you get this
right well
i talked about snail mail yeah well
either way either way right now real
world real world examples yeah like if
this was you know ronnie jackson sending
me a letter and i said i don't wanna i
wanna i don't want this and i wanna
return to sender right i'm rejecting it
right i'm letting the post office know
that uh i don't wanna take this so
they'll send it back to ronnie jackson i
see so spam kind of works the same way
where you without you know with the
click of a button without me having to
put a stamp or write a you know return
to sender i can just say marcus spam i
can also report it for phishing you know
if it's trying to take my information i
see report it for other malicious intent
um
i see i see it so yeah yeah yeah so it's
so very it's look look it's so easy
you know
a child can do it so so
so let me ask you on other spam issues
how then do you slice the spam
before you actually put it in the frying
pan how thin do you slice it i i'm i'm
not so sure that
how thin the slice the spam before you
fry it is there a specific
um um
measurement of spam that we should be
using to fry the spam
you know again i'm i'm i'm no chef i'm
just here for um for spam related
support at google you know from gmail
right um
i'm just making sure yes uh oh a
measurement of what you would slice it
at uh maybe we could google it do you
know how to google probably google yeah
[Music]
okay we'll check into that right so so
maybe like maybe like a quarter inch
okay i i prefer my spam sliced very thin
and it tastes and especially if you get
the soda sodium reduced it tastes a lot
like bacon i'm just saying just saying
it is pretty good have you ever have you
ever had you know not to go too far down
this rabbit hole but have you ever had
spam and eggs this spam and eggs is
families and rice you know that's right
that's right
that's a pretty good dish maybe ronnie
jackson should look into that kind of
spam maybe that would fix his problem um
so the one one last question that i have
here really is because here's the thing
is it seems like google and gmail what
ronnie jackson is describing is uh
wokeness are you guys gonna be bought by
disney any time soon because it seems
like all you woke companies are really
you know doing things like having a spam
filter so you know russian propaganda
doesn't end up in your mailbox you're
like disney you're trying to you know
support equity and equality that's
really kind of wokeness is disney buying
google is our gmail is that is that um
you're not sure you're not sure
there is no reason i mean like google
could technically try to make a bid for
disney
but that's not really within our
wheelhouse oh okay you know again we're
it's not that we're woke you know i'm
sorry to be the bearer of bad news but
we're not woke you know here we're not
suppressing people's emails
we're actually trying to protect you
um you know i mean even even you know
there was the gdpr which is the general
data protection regulation and that was
passed in the eu
whoa is that a different type of spam
can you buy that at the store is that
like you can't you can't buy that as a
store what did you say it was i'm going
to write that down so
gdpr gdpr that must be a nice um
does it taste better than spam the gdpr
couldn't couldn't tell you it is
european though so oh okay well maybe
that's strokes for different folks you
know how how thin do you slice this gdpr
do you slice it already you know thin
enough to
to make it so that you're you're good
you're safe you know good good huh yeah
yeah i i you know again we don't we're
not we're not big tech suppressing your
voice or anything what we are doing is
we are making sure that the bad people
the malicious the bad actors
are separated from the friends and
family that you normally you know send a
meme to
i see so good guy bad guy or whatever
you know yeah that's all we're doing you
know if i if i had more time if i had
more time i'd ask your opinion about
children's sidewalk chalk but i think
we'd get down a whole new rabbit hole of
uh how to cook how to cook children's
sidewall chalk so i'm gonna have to let
you go i appreciate you helping me with
my spam issue uh tech support um thank
you very much for
for coming on
and clearing up the spam issues that the
world has today yeah and remember if you
do have an issue do not fax us a letter
okay well
don't spam it's just don't spam the spam
filters please don't please don't spam
us
well thank you very much uh what would
james james was it from texas yeah all
right james thanks a lot stick around
everyone we'll be right back after this
after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50 a day
you can help us help those true
americans recover from biden's socialist
reign of terror these are those trump
supporters and this is that moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] em
[ __ ]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show thanks
for hanging through the break
[Music]
um gabe thank you for uh
going there it was very helpful they
really explained the ins and outs of
spam um and apparently they come up with
a new dish called uh gdpr or gpdr what
what is this do you know about this
are you talking about the wait i
wait gdpr is a dish
that's no no tony that's what is it what
is it that's a protection regulation oh
i thought i thought he was talking about
another type of canned meat that's what
he did you just talk to google support
and think you're talking about spam the
food well i mean it's confusing gabe
it's really confusing the internet gets
confused when you start to trend stuff
like spam i feel like i'm gonna have to
change your name to ronnie well
tony ronnie you know
i mean i've been drinking i've been
drinking this morning
of ronnie jackson this isn't coffee in
this mug it's um
it's bourbon um speaking speaking of
food there is there is a certain it is
taco tuesday right it is a story it is a
story out there and you are our local um
taco burrito connoisseur here
um gabe everyone gabe loves tacos and
this is i love tacos
but here's some news about uh taco bell
uh on taco tuesday it says dolly parton
this is nbc news reporting this this is
so this this is weird [ __ ] i don't know
i have no idea where this comes from i
don't know if this is the onion or what
but it says dolly pardon is starring in
a musical
about taco bell's mexican pizza that
will premiere on tick tock later this
month no no no no no no no no no no what
is this blasphemy why is somebody making
taco bells mexican pizza what is this
[ __ ]
i don't i don't well
for the audience to know out there gabe
does not think
that taco bell are tacos which i think
this
message right here just proved my point
why why does why does it prove your
point because
because of mexican pizza i'm not
claiming that mexican pizza is tacos
it's just a product that taco bell
but yeah but you look at taco bell and
i'd say i don't really classify those
things at tacos you know and then you
look at this and he's like oh they're
making a mexican pizza
oh boy and not only dale has a mexican
pizza they have one current i know but
what i'm saying is the mexican pizza
dish at taco bell only further proves
that tacos from taco bell aren't tacos
everyone is agreeing with you um
mj says gabe is right uh the 420 god
says it's not mexican
um
cindy says taco hell is not real food
i don't know i mean i mean you know
here's the thing
when i was a kid that was the only place
in town i mean besides making tacos at
your own house i i grew up in a small
town in the middle of nowhere so like
taco bell like if you wanted tacos
that's where you should probably move
you should move move to a better i mean
now now there's more there's you know i
like there's more available now this was
right you know years ago decades ago
sure yeah taco bell was the only place i
mean it was and here's the thing it was
a taco bell inside of a kentucky fried
chicken so like not only not only was it
taco bell that was the police see you
later bye see ya but it was it was a
taco i'm just telling you the truth i'm
not bullshitting you i would never [ __ ]
you you're my favorite turd listen the
taco bell was inside the kfc because
originally it was a kfc okay that's what
it was it was originally a kentucky
fried chicken and we did not have tacos
in our town you had to drive to another
town where they had a taco bell or an
authentic mexican restaurant yeah which
we did go to uh every so often
but in our town the only place to get
tacos was this
taco bell inside the kentucky fried
chicken
so is kentucky fried chicken not food
because if you're claiming that taco
bell is not fine i never said kentucky
fried chicken isn't food i said taco
bell isn't it no not real tacos not
authentic tacos now you could also say
kentucky fried chicken uh you know it's
just
yeah you know it's not like it wouldn't
be the place that was like oh you want
fried chicken like you should go to
kentucky fried chicken right obviously
what fried chicken place would you go to
if you went to a fried chicken place
what would you choose
i don't know i'd probably go to uh maybe
like uh like churches well or
i guess you'd go to churches but i'm
saying like you could also go to a
barbecue house right you get they got i
feel like they have chicken there too
so you want to get chicken wings you
don't necessarily want to get fried no i
get a whole chicken breast if i want
there's actually a spot that's in wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait a
second wait a second wait a second this
is breaking news
you're telling me you choose the chicken
tits over the legs and the wings no no
no no no no i'm not saying that what i'm
saying is you said you'd order you would
order the breasts yeah no i chicken
wings like i'm getting the drumstick i'm
wearing your wings but i'm saying like
i'm saying if i went to like a barbecue
spot like they typically give you
like the whole breast and they'll give
you like a drumstick kind of thing
that's what i'm saying like in addition
you know but if i was going to like go
watch the super bowl and someone was
like i got a bunch of wings coming yeah
i'll eat those
so you like the wings
i mean wings there's a there's the do
you hate the wings at hooters
once i'll see he's he's i went he's
dying and you know what he's trying to
dodge the question here for like
[ __ ]
what do you so so you do not like the
chicken wings at hooters
no i've only okay again i've only been
to hooters and he seems like he's
dodging the question here folks one look
at look we've been hooters once right in
the chicken wings there once
again where do you like chicken wings
from i mean that's the question well
there are several places in la that are
pretty good okay so let's let's break
this down let's figure out where in la
that gabe sanchez goes to make sure that
he's not offended by taco bell tacos
that he goes and eats because you know i
said the thing of the kfc and the taco
bell so where would you go to eat fried
chicken or chicken wings in general in
la where would you go um because we know
you wouldn't go to taco bell to eat
tacos no [ __ ] way right right right i
get it there's roscoe's you know chicken
and waffles that's pretty good
okay so roscoe's is a is a landmark
right yeah yeah it's it's well known
yeah yeah
um there's also uh the place called the
cluck and chucking or the the clucking
chicken
uh chocolate uh what the what i said
clucking chucking but i meant clucking
chicken oh oh what you see you get
confused when you say lube and driven i
know i know i know again you're getting
there's uh there's a there's actually a
spot that's across from um
uh the
uh the scientology
um
celebrity center okay that's called
birds that's pretty there's a
scientology celebrity yeah man there's a
scientology there's a frequent the uh
yeah they're they're well it's just it's
just in l.a right oh okay there's
there's the huge like
ominous right right the actual the main
one that's where all the people carry
the
you know suitcases
and then there's uh the celebrity center
then there's also like their studios
production house which is like where
they film all their stuff right
um but by the celebrity center across
the street next to one of the theaters
for ucb or you know what used to be um
is a place called birds there's also
harold's chicken that's pretty good
birds
is called
that's kind of that's kind of a weird
name like you would say oh birds we're
going to fry them and feed them to you
it's kind of weird right yeah yeah right
i'm going somewhere with this i promise
right okay
there's also a spot for people who live
in l.a or or visit la you definitely
should go check out yi rust again which
is like a chicago style bar but they
have some of the wing like the the best
wings i've ever had in the city and any
time i go there i'm always getting
a batch of you get the wings i get the
wings that's the only thing i have what
i get
and i get it
what do you get
on them oh okay okay here i ain't no
dipping sauce i don't do like the blue
don't put the sauce on i don't put sauce
on what i do is i put
buffalo the buffalo sauce they and then
they tell you what like spice level and
then they can also it's like regular
crispy extra crispy that's what you got
to do you gotta
get the breading the breading's gotta be
correct
that's that's why that's why i
like the hooters wings is because they
are the extra crispy and then they put
them in the sauce and they kind of saw
maybe
maybe tony maybe tony you should come to
l.a
yeah when we go to we will document a
document
for the people on the podcast now now
here's and we'll do a taco tour as well
that sounds well that was going to be i
was coming back around the tacos because
you're saying that mexican pizza
obviously mexican pizza is not tacos
it's a pizza that has taco on it or a
taco pizza right and it's at taco bell
now my question is if i were to go into
a kfc taco bell kfc slash taco bell and
i were to order a fried chicken taco
is if they made me in a kentucky fried
chicken slash taco bell they made me a
fried chicken
taco is that gabe now is that now
a taco that is the ultimate question
that everyone here on the podcast today
is wondering on taco tuesday
is that a taco
you know
am i am i
no
because it's still i don't know there's
something about
what is it what is it that doesn't make
the taco bell a taco i don't know you
know everyone in the chat agrees with
you about the tacos the taco bell it
might be the way that they prepared
right they like don't really melt the
cheese they put in just like
whatever [ __ ] lettuce uh they wrap
it in some flour tortilla
uh or they only have hard shell like i
think these are things where i'm looking
at this and i said
these aren't great right i prefer like
if you're gonna do if you're gonna do uh
a a flour tortilla
i wanna i want it real i want a homemade
i want a corn tortilla i want that real
homemade like that's the authentic stuff
uh typically i'll go with a corn
tortilla just hands down i don't do hard
shell i'm not into that
kind of thing i've done it before i've
had it at friends at friends houses
their mom made it for us they're like oh
we're making tacos tonight and it was
ended up being ground beef cheese
lettuce onions with a little tomato on
there and it's like making sure you
graduated it wasn't that i hated it i
mean it was just wasn't you know it was
no i said you ate it you ate it though
you were oh i ate it yeah yeah yeah i
ate it i didn't hate it i ate it it
didn't eat it didn't it didn't taste
that bad
right yeah it wasn't that bad you know
it's like whatever but it was like like
a homemade taco bell taco in other words
sure yes that's what you're saying
that's what you're saying it's taco bell
because they just put the ground beef
the seasoned ground beef the cheese the
lettuce maybe some tomato maybe some
sour cream in a flour tortilla or a
crunchy shell for that matter that to
you is the thing that doesn't that makes
it not a doctor it's just like uh
let's let's put a little more effort
right okay
i want to know i want to know and maybe
we should do a poll out there
if if you put fried chicken
if you put fried chicken
in inside that shell yeah
i just don't i just don't
i just don't think i just don't think it
holds well hard shells don't hold well
hard shells fall apart and you lose
everything and then this is what happens
is it because it cracks at the bottom it
does [ __ ] correct your hardships
you get a hardshell taco you bite into
it it breaks it falls into your taco
bell wrapping now the only way to eat
the rest of the taco is you got to pick
it up off and you got to eat it right i
would much rather have something that
molds to the shape right right it's
malleable i'm able to you know move it
around then what you want it to be
wrapped and nice and neat well yeah
maybe nothing tacos are normally neat
like you have the ability to have a taco
that's a little messy but it actually
has some flavor and even you know i want
to say this
it's the filler sawdust i don't know if
that's actually how they make their
stuff okay wait wait wait wait wait wait
what is amanda talking about here she's
talking about the meat
the meat i need is all that's talking
about the meat
come on
it's not salt dust and taco bell tacos
i've ate a lot of chocolate and there is
but what i am saying is that there isn't
real any flavor and it's almost like
you're eating sawdust oh i see what
you're saying so you're saying yeah
you're saying
i don't know if it actually isn't it i'm
just saying it tastes like it the
problem with taco bell tacos that you
have here is not really
it's not really kind of the way they're
made or how they're made i mean there
may be some you know debate on hardships
soft shell flour corn right
we could probably go round and round
about that
but what you're saying is it really is
the flavor that oh that makes it not a
taco is that yeah is that what i'm
gathering i think yeah they're you know
outside of the pieces that go together
to hold it you know i do look at i say
what does it taste like is it just
ground beef that's just been cooked
around and if they threw it in there
with a little you know uh
loose loose sauce or whatever
yeah you know whatever not really well
we'll keep debating this um on taco
tuesdays because i'm sure
um
gabe will
stick by his stance the taco yeah
i'm curious i will say this i am curious
to see what the hell this is you mean
dolly parton's musical about mexican
pizza at taco bell yeah like i don't
know
i don't know what happened here
what the hell does this do what is this
i mean i when i first saw this headline
i was like this
is this real life well you even said
you're like what the what right
because it you you sent it and i was
like
this is blasphemy this is not right i
don't know why we're making it what
doesn't make this right is this because
dolly parton is
almost in essence endorsing the mexican
pizza
taco bell or yeah
i'm like dolly pardon you could do no
wrong in my book until this moment what
if it what if it was instead of taco
bell was like dell tacos because isn't
that the other like
that's an alternative it's a it's better
i will say this del taco is better than
taco bell but still not authentic
mexican right it's not actual tacos it's
better
it is better than taco bell it tastes
better yeah i've had del taco more times
than i've had taco bell which is i've
had del taco twice and i've had taco
bell once
and maybe this is why you don't think
that uh
taco bell is a tacos you've only you've
only had them in your in your mouth and
next year
you only need
one time
to know well what is this what why what
is this musical stuff on on tick tock i
have no idea that is very weird
tick-tock videos aren't isn't the the
extent
ten minutes yeah so are they gonna maybe
it's a live that they're doing is a live
event
there was that well there was uh there
let me look it up real quick but there
was something that tick tock put on
where they made a whole play
um about
really uh
this is interesting this is this is hard
hitting stuff here uh mj says for taco
tuesday and softshell tacos never from
taco hell gabe wins the argument and
agreed the spices are so
gross at taco bell all right mj well mj
has spoken with the super chat here
thank you for the super chat let's let's
give the uh
you guys seen the new uh my gabe's
looking this up you see the new uh super
chat animation here
yeah
yeah thanks for the super chat um
so
so you're looking up this musical thing
right then you said there's something i
can find it but there was they put on a
play but it started as like a meme or it
started as a joke
and then what ended up happening is they
got
these people got back in from uh tick
tock and they did it it was during the
pandemic
um
so it was like it was like a there's
something alternative
from what what they would do live is
that what you're saying right um
yeah but man but dolly parton is poised
to do a musical which i i'm i'm excited
to hear dolly sing about me yeah that's
that's fine that's very yeah that's my
excitement very confused as to how that
came about ratatouille okay that's what
it was it was the ratatouille musical
that came together on tik tok and they
they did it but yes that was one
where they've already done a musical on
tick tock where i was like oh yeah sure
yeah ratatouille it's already thing
they're going to put it on right that
makes sense now
one that's about taco bell's mexican
pizza i'm like what's going on this
mexican pizza it's taco bell's song over
and over again listen taco bell's
mexican pizza dolly parton content is
the content that maybe america needs
because let me show you some content
that america doesn't need
and it's a book from this guy uh mark
esper have you heard uh yeah yeah
interview
um mark esper uh who is
oh my god um mark esper really
um
flew the coop here when he could have
told the american people what they
needed to know to make a decision about
a person who was trying to overthrow the
government trying to overthrow our
constitution and he didn't and now now
he's saying it now he's saying it this
clip especially because i think this is
the one that i know that you're going to
play right now this clip i
let's just play it let's let's just play
the clip and then i
do you think donald trump was a threat
to democracy i think that uh given the
events of january 6th given how he has
undermined the election results he
incited people to come to d.c stirred
them up that morning and failed to call
them off to me that threatens our
democracy so yes i think the answer
would be what else can you conclude
brett
oh man nope nope nope he does not get
this moment to redeem himself and say
that trump was a threat to democracy now
two years after the fact and say yo guys
got this book said some [ __ ] and uh i'm
actually a hero i'm a patriot because
that's what he's doing he's doing this
press tour doing this press junket
trying to make amends for the sins that
he had committed or rather the sins of
omission
because that's what really was he stood
by trump saw these things happen we even
played clips from last week where he saw
stephen miller say yeah we're gonna
we're gonna fund this team together to
do these things even though he said no
and he found out that they're doing
behind his back
and i look at this and i say
mark esper
cannot make up for the sense of omission
that he had during the presidency he
can't just retroactively two years after
the fact go listen uh trump was a
serious threat to our democracy um but
by my book right because that's what
they're that just like other people bill
barr and stephanie grisham and and all
the other people who have done the same
thing they try to profit off the
situation and i'm personally tired of it
because it's [ __ ] but someone who is
in the white house who could have said
something who could have done something
right especially this person just wasn't
like an aide he was the secretary of
defense and and realistically when
you're talking about the 25th amendment
because i think i think what he's
the other thing that he's doing here
is um
it is clear that the republican party
including mark esper understands what is
going to happen uh with the january 6 uh
insurrection and the investigations
around the january 6
investigations not only just the select
committee public hearings that are going
to come up that i think me and you are
going to live stream
to make sure our audience gets to see um
every single moment of those public
hearings but here's here's the thing is
i think what he's doing is he is he is
projecting because that's what they're
[ __ ] the best at they are so good at
projecting and what he is projecting
here is what is going to happen to the
republican party and the establishment
they're going to have to say that yes
the january 6 insurrection was an
attempt to overthrow our constitution
and that is the event that made donald
trump dangerous which is not i mean that
is true but that's not the whole truth
the whole truth is is donald trump was
dangerous the entire [ __ ] time he was
running for president the entire time he
was the president the entire time after
he was president because here he is this
weekend
his fat [ __ ] slob and i don't
normally play
clips of him talking that much i mean
normally we're playing as sycophants
talking for him but this is um
interesting in that he's standing in
front of a crowd who is about to watch a
movie called 2 000 mules which even fox
news and newsmax won't even play this
[ __ ] game yeah
newsmax is like yeah that's a little bit
too much of a lie well it's not even
bringing themselves to them well that
the reason is because they had that they
have that massive lawsuit which i think
is still litigating right now which is
uh
dominion and smartmatic were like hey
where they lie they lied about you guys
pushing this lie and that's why uh
people like michael and dell can't use
or advertise or or promote his own
um his own uh conspiracies there he was
like oh fox news won't play my stuff and
this and that i don't know he's getting
so upset and it's like dude all these
things are getting sued because you guys
pushed these [ __ ] lies and had no
literally no evidence right despite the
fact that you have this movie that's
great i guess good for you but it
doesn't mean [ __ ] because
if you did have evidence you would have
been able to bring it forward prove your
case but for that same reason
uh rudy giuliani any time he stepped up
to the court and the judge said you have
evidence he goes nope nope no no
evidence of fraud now this movie this
movie called
2000 mules of course it's [ __ ]
garbage it was i guess i guess made by a
couple cuban honors and dinesh d'souza
helped him out or some [ __ ] i don't
[ __ ] know who who knows um they've
sold less copies of this thing than i
think megan mccain sold to her audiobook
um
they're trying to hawk this thing for
like 30 bucks a pop if it really is if
it really is the evidence game if like
if this is the evidence that's going to
overturn the election and donald trump's
going to somehow be cool would you give
it away for free
right but not only give it away for free
wouldn't wouldn't wouldn't you be
standing on every street corner telling
people about it and all this right
they're they're [ __ ] grifting people
they're [ __ ] drifting but listen
listen to what the cheeto dust mobster
listen to what grandpa poopy pants here
donald trump himself
says about this film it is [ __ ]
ridiculous but listen evidence of this
documentary demands immediate action
from federal state and local law
enforcement
so he is saying the the the contents in
this film which even fox news and
newsmax will not play yeah if you can't
get newsmax to play you're crazy on [ __ ]
then you got a real you gotta look
yourself in the mirror and go
i mean the crazy one rsbn goes to trump
rallies and they're they're they're
asking people is jfk still alive like
you got damn right and he's the vice
president and they're like no the whole
2000 mules election fraud yeah we just
we're that's kind of gross right right
because i think i think with with people
you can play they're like oh that's the
that's their opinion that's what they
said we as the network don't believe
that but we're gonna let other people
speak for us now if you were to say hey
we're gonna play this movie that we also
endorse or promote or whatever
uh it says that the election was
rigged and there was all these fraud now
and if they push that then obviously
that's making the claim that's a
different claim right that's like i feel
like that's where the legal they can
they can play with public comments and
opinion
differently to say like well that's just
people saying that stuff it doesn't mean
that's actually true we're just letting
them talk right people say dumb [ __ ]
whatever
but then if you were to say oh let's
play 2000 mules then you're like
actually
uh this seems like a problem
david from facebook says 2 000 tons of
mule [ __ ]
you might even say it was 2 000 moscow
mules right that could mean that there
was a russian interference you've seen
the gif of uh the jurassic park when
jeff goblin walks up to the big pile of
[ __ ] that's exactly what i thought of
when yeah david he's like that's a big
pile of [ __ ] it's a big pile of mule
[ __ ] um uh
so um let's play i got hey if i can get
the comment over here i got one more
clip that i want to play of the cheeto
dust mobster here uh-oh um talking about
this documentary film which honestly
you're gonna see this a lot folks like
you're gonna see 2 000 mules like a [ __ ]
ton i've already seen it splattered all
over my tick-tock like in the comments
section and they don't really say
anything they just go type 2 000 mules
yeah like wait i
i do want to say i'm almost positive i
saw a message from chris
in our comments last week
on friday
he said he was going to watch two
thousand mules cause i said hey what's
everyone up to this weekend you guys
gonna like watch netflix or chill don't
have to be together you could do a
separate and he said he's gonna watch tv
and he's like i'm about to watch 2000
mules and i think he was probably paying
the 20 or 30 bucks or whatever so
whenever chris comes on tomorrow maybe
maybe he can tell us about yeah i don't
know how it was
yeah let us know how your 30 bucks
turned out here is here's this jackass
talking about 2 000 mules again
uh and he's talking about how dangerous
the country is i don't know a group of
people right here these are true
patriots salem they are true
great
patriots now same online massachusetts
no no no no no i think they're not the
witches this is the q and honors that
made this that made this film that
helped it helped dinesh d'souza with the
evidence or some dumb [ __ ] i don't know
but the because he that i guess because
i haven't seen the film and i'm not
going to watch the pilot [ __ ] because
you know it's a [ __ ] lie if he's
promoting it here's the thing and he's
and he's grifting off of it you know
it's a [ __ ] lie
but the the craziest part about it is
apparently they're not disputing that
there was that many votes what they're
saying is there was too many ballots
gave there was way too many ballots
the votes were correct i guess but the
ballots were i don't i did you [ __ ]
try to figure this [ __ ] out i i can't i
i don't know like does that mean that
they were they were extra ballot like
there were extra ballots sent to people
well that's what they're saying is
that's what they're saying is the
mailing ballots and the you know the
republicans you know the secret is and i
don't know if a lot of people know this
but the secret is with mail-in ballots
and absentee ballots that's actually uh
was always a republican stronghold
they always republicans always received
a lot of their votes from mail-in
ballots and from absentee ballots what
would happen a lot of times too is now
democrats would get their hopes up in
some of these races because the initial
showings of the race of the day's
election would be that the democrat was
either ahead or they were really close
and then the absentee mail-in ballots
would come in and of course they were
really weighted for republicans
but we know history and we know recent
history so we know during the pandemic
people were smart in in making sure that
they didn't get sick at like like a
polling station you know where you were
close in contact with people you were
trying to be safe and not spread your
covet or get right
just someone who cares you know as an
actual human being your community
another human being right well because
at the ballot at the bow locations that
actually is your community i mean it
really is right yeah exactly and not to
you not to try to wrap a little bow on
this but earlier we talked about the
confederate memorial day right this
losing the
losing um
uh traitor day
ah there we go he watched it free on
saturday but what i will say before we
jump into uh chris n and two thousand
mules of [ __ ] uh
i mean yeah uh you know whatever i mean
uh is the fact that
if there was any day that should be a
holiday
any single day they were like yeah we
should make this a federal holiday or we
should make you know it should be one
that allows people on election day to go
vote without having to worry about
juggling work and their family and going
here and running errands and doing this
and not have to squeeze it in before or
after during the lunch break and make it
a super stressful time right that's the
benefit that is that is the luxury that
we have as these mail-in ballots now
obviously republicans want to restrict
that they want to suppress that they
want to redistrict and make it even more
difficult to find we actually have to
vote we have to go two counties over or
whatever it might be
but if there's any day
any day we should celebrate as a true
patriotic day
for our country
it should be one that we have that's for
election day take the day off go do what
you need to do go vote that's a good
idea so all these states that have
trader day and they shut down the state
for trader today they really should move
it to election day and make sure that
their citizens can vote chris and our
our local hate watcher chris we love
having you here um he says i watched it
for free on saturday i don't know did
you hawk a copy or did you uh burn it
off
because man
i'm really concerned about the grift
here you're not you're not supplying the
cheeto dust mobsters pockets here i'm
really concerned chris let's listen to
what um
what uh
dumpy has to say here after he calls
salem the people who made this film
great patriots our country is going to
hell
and you know when they say two and a
half years i say are we going to have a
country in two and a half years because
i really don't know the answer i believe
that this is the most dangerous
period of time in the history of the
united states again this is the
projector in chief right now here's what
i believe he's doing here in gabe
because a lot of you are like oh this is
dangerous talk what he's what he's doing
is the same thing he did on january 6.
remember the december leading up to he
was like oh it's gonna be a great wild
thing in washington and and you should
come he's trying to get his supporters
he's like two and a half years that's a
long time you really what you really
should do supporters is try to over
overthrow the government and reinstall
me as the dictator right because we
won't have a country and that's what
he's [ __ ] saying right that's what
he's saying because he's terrified of
prosecutions oh absolutely terrified and
he knows that he knows that when he says
that we won't have a country in two and
a half years he means he won't have his
freedom because he's committed crimes
exactly in two and a half years that's
what i believe that he's uh i do want to
give an update i was able to quickly
easily follow or find uh 2000 mules on
the internet oh wow um
so just saying that's probably where
chris found it you know but
i wouldn't be surprised if other people
you know were like hey let me just turn
2 000 mules and you would easily find it
online i'm not going to say where you
can find it but
there's probably streaming sites uh not
the major ones but other ones that have
you know uh hd versions of movies that
you can just kind of watch on on the on
the browser
um
speaking of speaking of jackasses and
mules and uh
guys named donald trump uh donald trump
jr endorsed uh let's see endorsed uh ron
as here liz cheney's opponent apparently
the name is um how much weight does a
donald trump
who the [ __ ] would want to be endorsed
by this guy like even if i was a fascist
republican i'd be like man that's okay
you don't have to do a video you really
don't you really don't have to right you
don't have to man you don't have to do
especially when you're coked out office
videos but watch
watch in the [ __ ] video what it says
i'm gonna i'm gonna pause it and show
you because we're running out of time
here but watch this game that's why my
father and i endorsed harriet higgman
for congress he does the the [ __ ]
hand thing all the time what the [ __ ] is
this
well it's just it's
this is trump this is trump jr like when
he's doing his coked out videos he's
constantly beating the screen i don't
know what you know what it is can you
imagine if i just did this the whole
time we did the butt like just
boom boom people are listening are like
what are they doing you have to watch
what we're doing you have to watch do go
to youtube and subscribe
this is what i think is happening right
in between the movements of when he goes
like this right he's like dude
hand out little hands out to the side
right but in the middle he's like tying
and he's sewing he's sh and he's pulling
it
like it's like tying your shoe almost
yeah exactly but he's okay
and he's like
someone's like look you got it you can't
have your hands down at your side just
act like you're tying your shoes that'd
be perfect or or you might be like oh
it's like a marionette like he's like a
little puppeteer
yeah you know he's pulling the string on
some sort of uh
like doll yes just regurgitating this
right wing propaganda faked rigged
election 2020 trump is still president
coming back to 200 pounds of mule [ __ ]
exactly
let's watch what what it says on the
screen about this is a wyoming race
remember wyoming if you're familiar with
american geography you'll know where
wyoming is and where it isn't watch
closely hageman will defend our hegemon
will defend the border of wyoming
i i i i get what they're saying here
because it's supposed to be a member of
congress and defend
but these are wyoming voters um let's
continue
and our constitution defend our
constitution and by defend our
constitution she means definitely
definitely overthrow it yeah definitely
overthrow [ __ ] on it and wipe your ass
right right and make sure that donald
trump is crown king
that's why i'm joining president donald
trump why does he call his dad that
why just call him daddy right
you know
daddy carl you're right daddy trump
david endorsed by daddy trump my father
i love when he says my father my father
endorsed by president trump through
congress joe biden oh my god let's
finish
to officially endorse
congress she's the congresswoman wyoming
dessert thank god he officially did it
right like not not unofficially but
officially endorsed because i'm sure
that's going to really put her over the
top here uh you know i think it's going
to be really sad when when liz cheney
kicks their ass and they understand why
liz cheney decided to be on the to
appear to be on the side of democracy
not on the side of traders i mean she's
already raised a [ __ ] ton of money well
she is a ch
cheney yeah she's a change that is true
and i want to remind everyone uh one
more time
of the
the symbolism of what what donald trump
is doing here
by endorsing her her opponent
because on january 6 uh 2022
uh liz cheney and her father darth vader
dick cheney were the only republicans
who went to the floor of the house
to stand in solidarity with nancy pelosi
to remember
the lives that were lost on the day of
january 6 when they tried to overturn
our government and commit a coup those
are the only two republicans and here
donald trump jr is thinking that he's
gonna beat liz cheney darth vader jr
in a primary in wyoming yeah oh it
really is it's beautiful it absolutely
is beautiful
and uh hegemon i guess is her name
boy choosing
choosing to have donald trump jr endorse
you is almost as bad as south carolina
or any other state
uh deciding to shut down their state for
traitor day
on a taco tuesday gabe thanks for
joining us audience listeners thanks for
joining us out there make sure you go to
our youtube channel and subscribe
to our youtube channel you do not want
to miss a thing gabe tomorrow uh sounds
like we're going to have an interview
that we're going to play can you can you
let the audience know what's going to
happen we'll play a video later on on
twitter but who are we going to have
tomorrow
uh we're going to have a comedian a
friend he's actually a fellow actor that
we actually have class uh that i have
class with i think we talked about that
a little bit maybe yeah brent uh terhune
he is a comedian uh you might know him
on twitter
as
the guy with the with the beard and
the oakley sunglasses and the hat that
does the rants in the car right right
everything's satirical
exactly yeah so he's another comedian
that does uh satire and parody um very
funny guy we had him on the show it was
basically we just
[ __ ] [ __ ] for for an hour it's
hilarious you guys got to come see it
tomorrow we'll play it during the
podcast tomorrow um
so don't miss brent terhune on the tony
michael's podcast tomorrow
you know we will we will be live
tomorrow just like we are every single
weekday noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific on youtube twitter twitch don't
forget to follow us at all those places
also simulcasting from minus touch
facebook page
until tomorrow at noon eastern surf's up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking